it has bifurcated messenger muscles
over developed allowing for a much
stronger bite
hello my name is dr joy carter
i've been a practicing forensic
pathologist for more than 37 years
i am what they call the doctor of the
dead since i am examining deceased
people
and i can't get their history i have to
do a complete evaluation of their body
which is called the autopsy and today
i'm going to be
looking at the realism of autopsy scenes
in movies and tv shows
[Music]
can we cut to the money shot it's his
heart
so let's look at his heart opening
post-mortem incision beginning at the
midline of the sternum
um first of all is either one of them
a pathologist
second of all a person is supposed to be
confirmed
dead by electrocardiogram
third that no one's wearing a mask
fourth you do not open the body with a
saw like that
you make an incision with a scalpel
unbelievable
generally you have a mask over your nose
and mouth
you have eye protection on nowadays we
i wear transparent shield over
my glasses of goggles so that i am
protected from splashes of
blood and tissue getting onto my skin
uh you usually have an apron on and uh
you don't want blood or tissue soaking
through that very thin apron that he's
wearing
that's odd almost looks like he's
[Music]
bleeding
i've never heard of anyone waking up
during an autopsy there have been a few
close calls i've actually had a case of
someone got to the office
and they did have a minor uh fake pulse
they were immediately
sent to the hospital they were not in
the autopsy suite
but this is why you're supposed to make
sure electronically
by the ekg that there's no electrical
activity of
the heart well again there there's
usually
medical records whether it is from
someone pronouncing the person dead at
the scene
which could be a home or in a hospital
setting
i usually look for that pronouncement
time and someone who's qualified to
pronounce them dead
is not just feeling for a pulse as they
do on some shows that doesn't always
get it but generally those who need to
be in the autopsy suite
would only be allowed in the autopsy
suite because you're taking a risk on
exposure
to disease blood-borne pathogens
and also everybody's not suited to view
an autopsy
i have to give this a four
he's been dead a long time and i can
tell you it was not a poison
he was hemorrhaging internally and there
was a hematoma
in the rectus and the transverse
abdominis so we did die by eating
yes well at least they are showing uh
a proper y-shaped incision on the uh the
seat
there's the y-shape there coarsely
sutured
he's trying to describe the fact that
the stomach is distended with food
and uh that it has it has burst
from gluttony um
but he's pointing to something that
doesn't even look like stomach
and he's using language that doesn't
make any sense um one thing that friends
and pathologist is supposed to be doing
is being a bridge between the medical
community
and the police so make them understand
what you're talking about
well the condition is called morbid
obesity
and that is where you have a lot of fat
not only under the skin but surrounding
your tissue
and it actually can make it more
difficult to even receive
medical care this is not unusual
i i must say um
but the doctor said it took four
orderlies to move the body
if their well-trained autopsy system
probably two could do that
well i have worked on a decedent that
weighed over 710 pounds
the first problem was getting the the
seat removed from the place of death
i was working and there was the the
weight of the decedent was over 300
pounds
and i had myself into assistance
and we were actually trying to turn the
body and photograph the back because
there was an injury on the back of the
body
and the body began to shift the weight
and was coming off of the autopsy tables
oh we all reached out to keep the body
from
from falling off the table um i received
a
an injury i kind of pulled my my back
out but sometimes
i have used a step stool or a step
ladder if i have a really really long
large body and i need to get into body
cavities i'm gonna go back
to the number four here
two of her fingernails are broken off
and there's
there's dirt or grit i don't know it
looks like she's trying to claw her way
through something
i worked with the military i was a
military medical examiner
and the fbi agents do not do not examine
the bodies
this is not appropriate it's not
realistic
at all generally the forensic
pathologist works
closely with the local law enforcement
and they have detectives
who are specialized in investigating
homicides
or death scenes pretty much at the scene
the body belongs to the medical examiner
and the scene belongs to law enforcement
but they're not really supposed to be
touching the body
they are trying to depict a decomposed
body which has
a very strong odor some people try
to apply things like this vapor rug or
something strong
smelling within their safety mask
just having it on the top of your lip
does nothing she's got something in her
throat
they took a photograph and then from the
photograph
of the main character says she can see
something down in the throat
and you can't that's looking into the
mouth and then they pull out this thing
from
deep in the throat and there's no way
you can see that from that picture
decomposition begins uh in the mouth
area there's generally bloating green
black discoloration
and gaseous distinction or swelling the
tongue usually is protruding from the
mouth and it's dark
and the skin changes color so this is
not a realistic portrayal
of a decomposed body in fact this is
like a tongue with some coloring on it
it's not the way it would look and it
gives a misperception of how the
postmortem should be conducted
i'll give this a three stumps looks on
off
looks like this way down hacksaw maybe
the other body looks so fake i have
received bodies for examination where
limbs have been removed and
they're never that smooth and clean and
the muscles usually
a lot darker and redder these do
actually look like
i hate to say but they look like ham
it's like considered cutting
with a both multiple ligature marks
yeah choked in and out they are talking
about ligature marks and just you see
some faint
it looks like makeup on the on the body
or
mannequin whatever they're using it it
absolutely does not look real
you would expect a more of a human skin
tone
one ligature you can see there's a
little area of roughing skin
the other just look like marks if you
chop
the legs off with a machete you would
expect some irregularity in the skin
and some blood oozing out maybe some
fragments of foam
if you use a different type of saw you
might have a different cup but you would
absolutely have what we call striations
in the bone and
that would give you some information as
to what a tool was used
so i have to give this one one it's it's
just
it's not realistic there's a
ligature mark that stretches across the
victim's neck the width looks consistent
with the twine we found
there are occasions where you have to
examine whatever
is found well i've come across similar
scenarios where i'm presented with a
part of the body that has to be examined
what's really important is working
closely with the police officers to try
to determine the identity of the person
so if you don't have the body
and you can't get fingerprints then you
can
in this case there's a head so you would
actually do a dental examination
first or if there is perhaps the body
is somewhere else the torso was found
somewhere else you want to see if those
match up then you want to try to do dna
you can still get dna evidence from the
body from the mouth from the tongue
from the skin
[Music]
this is a very dramatic depiction of
getting
what we call vitreous fluid which is
fluid obtained from
the eyeball or the ocular globe that
actually is what we do and pretty much
only we do that
but it's very dramatic to show the
needle enlarged like that
it looks like they just got the fluid
out of the eye and they
automatically have an answer like within
seconds they know exactly what's in that
fluid so
unrealistic i have dealt with body parts
having been a military medical examiner
investigating plane crashes sometimes
you have body fragmentation
or explosions
war crimes um for me the challenging
part is i want to make sure that the
families get their
loved one back this show
uh gives a lot more power and authority
to crimes and investigators than they
actually have
well i i would give this an eight out of
ten no
inflammation no fluid and no foreign
substances
and ear canals are
clear he's making statements of things
he really can't see
he's going over and peeking at the ear
and saying nothing's there
his vision is not going into the ear
itself
i'm not saying that cannot happen but
generally the flies coming out of the
body there's usually
uh maggot activity generally the flies
lay eggs
on the outside of the body and then the
eggs hatch into maggots and the maggots
actually do the
additional work going inside of the body
[Music]
the bell on the toe that actually was
true back in the 19th century
and the 18th century when we didn't have
electronic means of determining death
had occurred
they actually would have things like
bells they would even have
a clear glass in the casket
some caskets even had daggers that were
applied and if they did
if they weren't uh dead then they moved
around they'd actually be stabbed to
death yeah back in the day before we had
the electronic means you could have
a brain stem injury you could have very
shallow breathing that could be mistaken
for you being dead
we don't put bells on on toes we use
things like toe tags that have their
written identification information
so i give it a a four
micro probe thingamajig goes right here
there's very little of merit but what's
interesting is they're doing an autopsy
and all those fluids hanging down and i
don't know why
you have bags of fluid hanging down to
do an autopsy you're not resuscitating
anybody
so that's a surgical setup there
all right now spread it very very gently
let me get in
disgusting
i i don't know what style of blade this
person is using
well that blade looks like something you
would use to fillet fish
uh generally we use a scalpel and we
have removable blades
uh that looks like a very it's curved so
it tilts up not the kind of blade i
would use
to open up the body and of course
generally we would uh cut the ribs or
use a bone saw for the ribs
of not the right instrumentation also
looks like just one
thin pair of gloves and you have no idea
what that alien
uh substance is uh i always wear at
least two pair of gloves sometimes three
i'm gonna rated the two because they try
to set up a surgical suite
they've tried to make it look scientific
i'll give an effort for that
[Music]
oh my god you want me to um
take a sample or yeah i want you to move
away from the table
well good they actually have on
appropriate
protection personal protection equipment
they have on mass they have on shield
they have a hair bonnet on
it is realistic in that you actually can
reflect the scalp but then you have to
take some time to open the skull
and then say there's something wrong
with the brain
you do have to very carefully uh make an
incision into the scalp
usually way behind the head actually at
the
behind the ears so that you can reflect
the scalp
and see what is underneath the scalp
itself which is tissue and fibrous
tissue
there should be a bit more blood than
that
and then you take the bone saw and you
actually have to
open the skull you would have to
actually
take the brain out of the body and
dissect the brain
to say there are problems with parts of
the brain just by looking into the top
of the head
so i expect to see um the skull which
also contains blood vessels
and then there's fiber that's attached
to the skull
which we call the dura base of the skull
can have fractures and discoloration
and you can expect that the brain would
be soft
sometimes liquidy discolored
perhaps a bloody film over it if
somebody has an infectious disease
well i would give this an 8 out of 10.
it is more realistic in what is trying
to depict
you called me doc yes yes my initial
assessment of petty officer kettering's
cause of death
has proven to be correct it was uh it
was strangulation
i
i i just don't understand
um they pulled the sheet up on the
cadaver but they're not showing any
incision
and you would have to have an incision
and examination of the neck in order to
talk about strangulation
and you are looking at the neck organs
to see if the hyoid bone
is broken a damaged hyoid bone
would be a telltale sign of
strangulation but it's not applicable in
this case
and why is that because our victim is 26
which
is relevant because because the hyoid
bone doesn't fully form until the age of
30.
very good doctor thank you doctor why do
i need to be here
now uh we're born with high wood vowels
they're just not fused
so nothing is not formed it's present
and it can actually
uh fuse in the late teen years so that
doesn't mean
that it doesn't form until age 30. so
that that's a misnomer
during our examination we found this
rash on her neck
and lower back poison ivy oh not at this
time of year
no whatever caused this is inorganic one
doctor i presume he's a doctor i'm not
sure
the younger person
i don't understand why they're giving a
cause of death in the way that they are
and and changing it
hypoxia is lack of oxygen
and that's the outcome of asphyxia but
you can have
hypoxia from multiple forms
and i don't understand how they switch
over from
that to talking about an inorganic rash
i think i would give this a i'll give it
a six for effort
it has bifurcated massachusetts muscles
over-developed
allowing for a much stronger bite
neurotoxin scene is
is so ridiculous first
there's so many things wrong the main
one is
you put the neurotoxin and smell it
inhale it into your own nose that
neurotoxin is going to go straight into
the central nervous system
second of all rigor mortis begins within
generally two hours of death and it
begins actually in the head region
goes down from the head to the toes
and it's all about the muscles being
stiff so when they're talking about
masseter muscles and the tongue is a
muscle
also that can get stiff as
does the jaw can i give it a negative
if i can't then i will give this a one
secondary injuries are post-mortem
basic skull was punctured by a broken
tree branch
the doctor just reaches over and pulls
out this big stick from the head
well the first thing that i would do is
an x-ray to see where the
tree branch is penetrating and then
you'd get good photographs
i would probably shave the hair around
where it's entering so i can get a good
look at that
and i wouldn't just yank it out
you want to determine what part of the
skull is damaged what type of entrance
it was
they have the the skin reflected but the
rib cage is not opened
and so she didn't finish the first part
of the job the last thing you generally
do is the head examination
if i were to rate this scene it would
probably fit in the one category
it's not realistic at all